Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This episode is about simulating a beautiful
phenomenon in nature, the buckling and coiling
effect of honey.
Mmm!
This effect is due to the high viscosity of
materials like honey, which means that they
are highly resistant against deformation.
Water, however, is much less viscous as it
is held together by weaker intermolecular
forces, therefore it is easier to deform,
making it so easy to pour it into a glass.
We had an earlier episode on honey buckling,
and as every seasoned Fellow Scholar already
knows, the link is available in the video
description.
One key difference of this work is that the
older solution was built upon a Lagrangian
approach, which means that the simulation
consists of computing the velocities and the
pressure that acts on these particles.
It is a particle-based simulation.
Here, a solution is proposed for the Eulerian
approach, which means that we do not compute
these quantities everywhere in the continuum
of space, but we use a fine 3D grid, and we
compute these quantities only in these gridpoints.
No particles to be seen anywhere.
There are mathematical techniques to try to
guess what happens between these individual
gridpoints, and this process is referred to
as interpolation.
So normally, in this grid-based approach,
if we wish to simulate such a buckling effect,
we'll be sorely disappointed because what
we will see is that the surface details rapidly
disappear due to the inaccuracies in the simulation.
The reason for this is that the classical
grid-based simulators utilize a technique
that mathematicians like to call operator
splitting.
This means that we solve these fluid equations
by taking care of advection, pressure, and
viscosity separately.
Separate quantities, separate solutions.
This is great, because it eases the computational
complexity of the problem, however, we have
to pay a price for it in the form of newly
introduced inaccuracies.
For instance, some kinetic and shear forces
are significantly dampened, which leads to
a loss of detail for buckling effects with
traditional techniques.
This paper introduces a new way of efficiently
solving these operators together in a way
that these coupling effects are retained in
the simulation.
The final solution not only looks stable,
but is mathematically proven to work well
for a variety of cases, and it also takes
into consideration collisions with other solid
objects correctly.
I absolutely love this, and anyone who is
in the middle of creating a new movie with
some fluid action going on has to be all over
this new technique.
And, the paper is absolutely amazing.
It contains crystal clear writing, many paragraphs
are so tight that I'd find it almost impossible
to cut even one word from them, yet it is
still digestible and absolutely beautifully
written.
Make sure to have a look, as always, the link
is available in the video description.
These amazing papers are stories that need
to be told to everyone.
Not only to experts.
To everyone.
And before creating these videos, I always
try my best to be in contact with the authors
of these works.
And nowadays, many of them are telling me
that they were really surprised by the influx
of views they got after they were showcased
in the series.
Writing papers that are featured in Two Minute
Papers takes a ridiculous amount of hard work,
and after that, the researchers make them
available for everyone free of charge.
And now, I am so glad to see them get more
and more recognition for their hard work.
Absolutely amazing.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!